pulls up against Owen power and a fe into the
middle blocked Away by Eric Robinson and up
ice comes Robinson one-on-one against bahala
backand and a save Thompson William Carlson
Jonathan Maro cuts it to the slot finds eel
looking in front to Stone saely by he was
spread out and got the right pad on it inside
six minutes to go in the first period Marsh's
so at Center lead pass to Brett Howen racing
in head shot at Levi able to turn that away
into the middle cter back to H and the given
go shot turned away by Levi revine to H shot
and Levi got across to get a piece of that and
cover it now denene snaps it out cousins first
one up ice and a gate the icing and a center
it and a good chance in typ for tur denied by
Thompson out High Johnson bumped on the play by
Stone Michael through Center to barers panelo
joins the rush in the Middle Stone and a saely
by but close and now he's able to cover it four
of a five game swing for the vgk Yoki Haru starts
it out up ahead now of pton KBS cross to peterka
and a save M Thompson it's a Sabers Power Play
That's gone two for their last 27 and up I here's
Jack Kel short handed trying a cut to the net
and Levi got a pat on it think Dalene broke it
up back the other way Thompson to PKA walking
in shot a save made by Thompson back the other
way comes Stone alone on the rush short-handed 10
seconds left on the Stevenson Miner Casey middle
stat into the offensive end broken up W second
effort gets it out and then Kar may have taken
an elbow from cousins back the other way comes
cousins and he scores Dylan cousins his first
in 12 games breaks the ice for to get him going
as little play into the Zone he's going to take
that Fe cut right between the legs of McNab using
the defens a bit of screen just pass that stick
and pass the Blocker of Logan Thompson and Dylan
cousins fifth of the Season penson had a jump off
his stick to barev his passing the skates of eel
back the other way Benson cousins into the zone
and a save Thompson Dylan cousins looking for
goals on consecutive shifts Carlson up the wing
and stone couldn't get it out cous it's a big
h and a big collision with barers shf Carlson
has a breakaway backand and Levi made the Stop
and stone couldn't bear the rebound the puck to
Center Ice Alex tuck against Nick H he finds
Thompson save Thompson and in and Tu couldn't
bury it Zack White Cloud diving back was a stick
to knock that rebound for tuck up and out of
Play Why inde shoves it around the
wall for Stevenson in the middle
barers had to go off his skate wall
puts it towards the N block second CH
score now the golden night table of Barry and
Ivan Barbers crashing the net and it's a power
play goal to tie of the game why they got him
driving the net this Puck is bouncing around
wall gets a shot and what barers goes to the
hard area takes the hit at the end end of it
but he gets the shot away going hard to the front
of the net gets enough of that power he runs into
him that is just a hard goal going to the hard
area as barbashev able to tie this game up at
one a power play goal for Vegas petrangelo with
the line Maro give go with petrangelo down low in
front conter and a sa made leevi Carlson takes it
away Mio couldn't settle land Puck white L along
wrist shot save Levi rebound and Carlson tried to
bury it I got blocked in front Carlson leaning on
him the pry at fre Puck loose back out high for
tangelo Michael walking in shot and a glum save
Lei makes his way to Center pass into
the middle blocked and Benson able to
gain control Now power pass p picked
off by eel cter on the counter attack
CER trying to dangle around power put
it on net Z rebound score Jack eel puts
it home after a beautiful Rush by Paul
conter and the golden knights have the
lead conter we've seen this move between the
legs get it to the forehead just gets a chance
and there's eichel drifting across the top of the
crease as cauter great work to get that shot away
and eel able to rip it past Levis can't get to
that side of the net what a move cter not only
between the legs but getting it back sticking
with it being middle stad looking and a shake
Howen puts it across the slot Clifton will keep
it in pass picked off by Stevenson and had a
poke check way down low cousins out High Middle
St score short side Casey middle stad and the
Sabers come right back to tie the game that
leads to Extended offensive zone pressure by
the Sabers and eventually little play cousins to
middle and what a shot that is there is not much
room you've got an elevated short side and that's
exactly what he does over that left shoulder of
Logan Thompson as Casey midat is seventh in the
sabers TI two and up feed Thompson but Carlson
on the back check HCK along the wall Thompson to
Benson Thompson able to hold the short side post
straightway samelson looking wrist shot block tuck
down L Benson a backand and he scores Zack Benson
with goals in backto back games to give Buffalo
the lead Benson tried a little short side play
but buffo maintains possession just a shot it's
going to get blocked in front by petrula but a
good effort as tuck gets a stick on it in the
slot right over to Benson and he's able to go
the back hand lift it over that left pad of Logan
Thompson and Benson 13th overall pick this past
draft barers able to roll right off of Robinson
roll off roll through then turn it over look out
Benson with tuck tuck to en he scores golden I
victimized by the turnover and Alex tuck puts it
all for the third straight goal for the Savers the
other way there's the turnover Henson gets it he
fires it over to tuck he's going to go top Corner
pass Thompson and just like that the Sabers strike
quickly to grab a 4-2 lead as Alex tuck has his
ninth of the season now Stone protects it in the
corner pass picked off and not clear loose Puck to
cousins up ahead here's middle stad has PKA and he
scores casy midad second goal of the period
second goal tonight to seal this for the Sabers
period Hunton kind of hesitates that leads to
the two-on-one and that's just going to hang on
patrul at some point you have to challenge
you can see slides towards but forces that
shot and able just lifted over the body of
Alex petangel and put it in the net so gold
Knights run a not happy hockey team here on
Sunday it's a 5-2 win for the Sabers in Vegas
tonight paced by 33 saves from the youngest
golender in the league 21-year-old Deon Levi